in this video we'll talk about rapid
urease test for detecting helicobacter
pylori in a person's stomach
let's talk about how does this test work
so half of the world population has
helicobacter pylori in their stomach and
many cases helicobacter pylori can lead
to serious gastric complication
in this video we'll try to understand
how this test really works
so it's a rapid urease test that means
it's a simple and rapid test and in this
test
the decision is made by color changing
so it's pretty much visual let me tell
you how
so first of all your doctor
using endoscopy takes out a small
portion or a biopsy of your mucosa from
your stomach antrum
then
it is
transferred to a test strip
and in this test strip there is a zone
which forms a color
now if the color is actually red that
means helicobacter pylori is present
and if the color is yellow that means
helicobacter pylori is absent
and the test is negative
so let's try to understand what is the
basis of this color change and why the
color is changing and what does it tell
us
so here is how the test is performed the
biopsy sample is provided into the
desired region generally the test strip
should have a yellowish patch on that
and if the test is positive
then the color would change
this yellow patch should generally
contain urea in a moment it would be
clear so this particular
patch has a particular ph indicator
which is known as phenol red
when it is near to neutral the color is
yellow that is why generally the color
of that strip is yellow but when
the
media turns into a basic situation and
ph rise up then the color becomes
reddish
and that's what happens in helicobili
helicobacter pilory infection
so in the test trip when you see a red
color that means positive result
you see the bacteria is present this
bacteria
actually produce one enzyme which is
known as urease that can convert urea
into ammonia
ammonia is kind of basic
that is why whenever the bacteria is
present urea's enzyme is present and
urea gets converted into ammonia that is
why the color is turned into red and
that means the test is positive
in contrast when the helicobacter pilot
is not present urea's enzyme is not
present so urea is not getting converted
into ammonia so it's kind of
like in a neutral stage
that's why the test is now negative and
that's why you see a yellow patch not a
red patch
so let us try to understand the
infection and the biology behind that in
a bit more details to understand the
test and the treatment in a better
fashion
so helicobacter pylori enters your body
through and kind of attacks the lining
of your stomach it can enter your body
via food water etc
so the layers are actually protected by
a thick layer of mucosa
and let's see what happens when
helicobacter pylori infects it creates
ulcer
in the stomach
now the gastric mucosa
secretes thick mucus
and in top of that there is gastric hcl
and this kind of protective layer
ensures majority of the bacteria dies in
this extremely extremely acidic
environment
but helicobacter pylori has this enzyme
known as urease
which can
actually
prevent or buffer this kind of extreme
uh level of p extreme lower ph in the
stomach
so urease converts urea into ammonia and
that's the basis of this test
and that kind of neutralize the
excessive acidity
in the stomach
now there are other molecules which help
these bacteria to get attached to the
stomach wall
and the flagella that is present in this
bacteria helps it to propagate and do
the chemotic taxes and get attached to
this particular
stomach wall
and there are other toxins that are
secreted by the bacteria which leads to
serious damage
to the
mucosal lining it actually can
lead to a huge inflammatory response and
also can lead to apoptosis of these
cells
anyway
we understand the biology in bit more
details but let us try to understand the
false positive result
sometimes you see this red color
formation
but it does not always ensure that your
test result is positive because if you
are consuming a drug which reduce the
acidity of the stomach and that can
possibly contribute to the false
positive result because
then the mucosal biopsy would have a
alkaline kind of situation that converts
the color in this particular test strip
into reddish situation which is
indicative of a positive test result but
in this case it's a false positive
result
so i hope this video was useful anyway
the treatment of helicobacter pylori can
be done with the help of proper
antibiotics
and
your doctor can prescribe all of these
antibiotics so if you think you are
positive to this particular test do
consult a doctor
all the notes regarding these topics
would be found in my facebook page don't
forget to like share and subscribe
and you can support my channel on
patreon
if you are a indian viewer you can
subscribe to my un academy
courses
using my code ap10 you can get a 10
discount see you in next video do let me
know in the video whether it is useful
or not thank you